tonight is the premiere of bel air
the pilot is crazy the pilot is
ridiculous and it's strange because of
covet i've never actually
met jabari in person we've only ever
zoomed
what's up philly what's up y'all i'm
good i'm good
he plays will in the new bel air and we
literally have never met
in in person he's doing a great job in
the show so we'll uh we'll see is he on
his way is jabari on his way
in in a sec jazz do you know that like
specifically or are you guessing jazz is
standing here right now and he doesn't
know whether jabari is actually coming
because he's been here with me so that's
firsthand knowledge so i have first-hand
knowledge of that um uh i'm excited i'm
gonna just
uh i'm gonna show him some movie star
stuff
um just you know just just how to be
will do you know
yo what up jabari banks here on my way
to the premiere getting ready the big
day is here
man it's been such a beautiful ride and
um we worked so hard to be here hey this
is my mom behind me
yeah man i've been waiting for this
moment my whole life my whole life and
uh and it's so special to a lot of
people and so i'm super excited for
everyone to get to see bellaire
where am i right now this is crazy right
oh man the anticipation
is giving me bubble guts right before
you're on the precipice of something
really exciting it's just like uh you
know all the tension is right there and
so you know i'm ready i'm ready what if
he doesn't like me
what if he thinks i'm corny and old all
i can do is dance man all i can do is
dance in this moment
you build up all of this and then he
sees me you know
and he's like oh
no and then i'll get it
okay
wish me luck
oh i should answer the door too
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
congrats thank you man we've never
actually met in person it's your first
time meeting in person you look good i
mean you know i'm saying so do you think
i was like okay okay you're gonna be
proud right you're with me proud
shooting's been good oh man it's been
it's been wonderful it's been a blessing
man and there's uh there's so many
beautiful people on that set man and
they're working really hard to to make
this dream a reality so yeah so i've
been i've been in the pilot and it it is
it's
blazing yeah that thing is crap i can't
wait for people to see this oh yeah me
too me too i know my mom's gonna cry i
know y'all oh so you haven't seen it no
oh i love that i love that
oh man the feelings that are going
through my body right now is very
special i knew that this moment was
gonna be special but being here right
now man this is just really out of body
yeah
the fresh prince is really
what
made my career yeah you know
and i just i want you to know i'm
available to you yeah and uh you know
quincy quincy jones walked me through
this this process when i was your age so
i'm excited to be here for you and help
you capitalize on all that you you got
happening let's do it let's do it let's
go i'm ready man i'm ready i'm ready
i haven't been this hype for something
in a long time this has been
two and a half years in the in the
making oh yeah and we're here tonight
premier bel air jabari banks
and i gotta tell you i got to tell you
my mom she bought us christmas sweaters
with your face on it
i've had that for years
your mom's like listen i i like the
fresh prince but i'm not sure
[Applause]
me somebody
[Music]
you